erst miteinander hier ist wieder
unterwegs sind dienste des tm hd ist
deutschen metzger handwerks leider
musste ich in letzter zeit immer wieder
beobachten dass gäste in einem lokal im
lack dass die wenn ich ihnen eine
wunderschöne wurstplatte als vorspeise
empfohlen hat die dass die gesagt kommt
wir hätten lieber italienische antipasti
weil die china viel besser aus und
schmecken viel besser sie wissen das
vielleicht bei mir ist der kunde könig
und wenn der kunde italienische
antipasti will kann sich
selbstverständlich um aber nicht bei mir
die sollen ihren italienischen
scheißdreck fressen wo sie wollen aber
doch nicht beim chio was
die preußen schon der frühe aus
schauen sie sich das mal anschauen sie
sich das mal an schauen sie sich diese
wunderschöne presse
dies ist ein hochgenuss damit man sofort
wenig eigen nehmen und herzhaft hinein
beißen wo es immerhin weißen in einlegen
möchte man sich in diese presssaft leute
sich darin wälzen da drin und kugelt das
ist sinnfrei wie es sein restliches
leben möchte man in dieser partie
verbringen aber auch hier gibt es
möglichkeiten das optische
erscheinungsbild dieser köstlichkeit zu
optimieren dekorieren ist das zauberwort
dass wir seine schatten vorauswirft
- doch einfach liegen vielleicht von mir
aus zwei ein bisserl alberta sie um der
festschmaus die auch höchsten optischen
ansprüchen genügt kann genügen
da kannst du diesen italienischen trägt
direkt in die heimischen kinos immer
wieder song wurst aus deutschland ein
hochgenuss
[Applaus]